tony is with us in baltimore hi Tony how
are you I'm stressed oh how can I help
all right so here's the deal
my mother-in-law is the cosigner on my
wife's student loan and her car loan and
we're trying to to follow baby step - my
wife and I did theft to you and they
were both working two jobs I'm driving
left even though I have a salary but
anytime we don't pay on the student loan
my mother-in-law pays on it and we catch
the backlash because she doesn't tell my
father-in-law why wouldn't you pay on
the student loan if you're banking on if
you're out there working your butt off
working baby step - well it's a little
bit further down I've got a bunch of
medical debts and a bunch of stuff for
my first marriage as we're going by
numerical value no I didn't tell people
to not pay our bill in the decimal like
it's below the line right now after we
pay rent after we don't have the money
why all your bills you're not in baby
step - okay yeah that's where I'm at you
know baby step 0.5 yeah you got to get
current on everybody first so what's
your household income uh it fluctuates
I'd say between 80 and 90 okay and how
much is the student loan debt $80,000
good lord
and how much is owed on her car fix I'm
actually paid two hundred dollars a week
on that to get it paid off faster good
that's going to free up some room wait a
minute you're paying extra on it well
I'm paying $200 a week is that a normal
payment no so you're paying extra on it
yeah meanwhile not paying the student
loan on time
yes wrong
so are
rule is let's get current with everyone
before we pay extra on anything okay and
I don't blame you for wanting to get her
out of your ear and I'm trying to help
you do that okay so you have six
thousand and eighty thousand and one
other bit and you got medical bills how
many medical bills I lost count I didn't
have health insurance when I was younger
no Lord and what's a bunch of that in
default yeah have you got a bunch of it
on payments or you just paint it as you
can I'm paying it as I can okay how much
total is that I believe my wife figured
all of that out I didn't and I haven't
written in front of me we'll give me a
guess 20 or 200 I'd say about 20 it's
it's a lot of little stuff got you a lot
of little ankle-biters okay what other
debts that $7,000 on a car that was
repossessed when I was younger are you
paying anything on that not right now
good
okay don't right now okay the medical
bills that do not have any payments on
them that you haven't worked out a deal
with don't pay anything on them set them
aside set the repo to the side for now
what other things have you got we owe
that six grand on my car okay so six
grand each on two cars and you're making
80 mm-hmm good did you say you met your
household income is 80 give or take only
with my wife a server okay and how much
is and how much is your rent 1150 okay
you guys need to do a written budget and
you need to personally get involved and
see the numbers in the budget so you
know what they are and can answer any
questions when you and I talk again
Pacha
okay you need to get more involved
because she's carrying all the weight of
this by herself and she's having a
cringe every time the phone rings and
the ID says her mom's number yeah so you
guys make enough to pay minimum payments
if you don't pay anything on the medical
bills except what you've already agreed
to do and you don't pay anything on the
repo right now and you pay the student
loan minimum and you pay the car payment
minimums you make enough to do that and
eat and still have money left over to
working your dead snowball gotcha so get
current stay current that's then let's
save a thousand dollars baby step one I
got that okay you got more I weep let me
capped it at a thousand and we kind of
refill it I'm in the middle of a custody
battle okay all right you have any other
money in any kind of investments no okay
all right good so let's pay minimum
payments on everything walk through a
bunch of those ankle-biters any of the
medical bills that you promised to pay
knock them out the ones that you're not
paying anything on set them over on the
side like I said okay then let's clean
up let's clean up the medical bills your
pain payments on the two car payments
first then you stay current on the
student loans then we'll go and do
settlements with those old medical bills
and that old repo you can settle that
own repo for about 1500 bucks if you
negotiate it be sure you get any
settlements in writing and be sure you
do not allow them to have electronic
access to your checking account so there
you go get after if they hold on I'm
going to send you a copy of the book the
Total Money Makeover hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]